تناولنا امس فيديو متداول الفيديو او
لوزير التجاره العراقي اثير الغريري خلال
جوله رسميه تعامل فيها مع مواطن كبير في
السن بطريقه اعتبرها البعض انها مسيئه
خلينا نذكركم بالفيديو
من اليوم
من هذا الفيديو انطلقت حمله دعت لاقاله
الوزير ومن بعدها الوزاره نشرت بوست قالت
فيه انه الفيديو مو حقيقي ومو كامل وانه
الوزير نادى وصرخ عليه علشان يجي لعنده
ويحل مشكلته وطلبت من المواطنين توخي
الدقه الجديد اليوم هو اخبار عن تدخل رئيس
مجلس الوزراء محمد الشياع السوداني بالقصه
ومصادر قالت داخل مكتب رئيس الحكومه اكدت
انه تواصل مع الوزير وانه وبقوا على
اسلوبه اللي تعامل فيه مع الرجل وقال
المصدر انه السوداني راح يطرح خلال جلسه
مجلس الوزراء الجيد تعليمات واضحه للوزراء
بخصوص ظهورهم الاعلامي وعدم الاستعراض من
دون عمل هذا الكلام كله نشره اعلام حسب
مصادر داخل مكتب رئيس الحكومه مثل ما قلنا
تطور اخر في القصه كان ظهور المواطن اللي
كان بطل الفيديو الاساسي في فيديو جديد
بيشرح فيه اللي صار وبيقول اصلا ما في
مشكله والوزير مشكور حل
مشكلتي وعتب على الاعلام
في هذا المكان في سالو كركوك أنا
وكليه اريد اصور محصوله وكنت متاخر في هذا
المجال
كنت اني بعيدا عن معالي الوزير وناداني
بصوت عادي
فذهبت اليه
وسالني وعاتبني لمقاطعته بالحديث مع
المواطنين
وسالوا ما قال الامام مشكلته وحده اثنين
ثلاث لان لان انا متاخر
بتصوير محصول لهذا رابع يوم
وقام بحل مشكلتي وتصوير محصول
وشاكرين معالي الوزير وذلك هذا الاعلام
الذي قام بتاويل قصه المناداه السيد وزير
التجاره بصوت عالي اتجاهي
فقاموا بتاويل هذا الكلام اتجاه معالي
وزير التجاره
مشكوره قام بحل مشكلته وتصويق محصول
بثلاثه وبسهوله وما كان اي مشكله حدثت
بيني وبينه شاكرينه وشاكرين من ساهمه بحل
هذا المشكله
والموضوع
اي مشكله